so the self-inflicted damage for donald
trump
continues to be done the doctor who
developed
the montreal cognitive assessment that's
the so-called test that trump took and
claims he aced
the doctor that created that test has
come out and said listen
this is supposed to be an easy test it's
really just meant to screen out
relatively serious cognitive decline
and remember that this is now relevant
again because in donald trump's
bizarre interview with fox news host
chris wallace over the weekend
trump talked about how he aced the test
joe biden couldn't do well on the test
trump said
trump said the last five questions are
really tough
and at one point when chris wallace said
they're not really tough
trump accused chris wallace of being
unable to answer some of the questions
it was completely outrageous as far as a
thing to say
but more importantly the real story here
as we're now hearing as we hear from the
doctor who developed the test
the story is that trump found some of
the questions difficult
that's really the red flag here's a
reminder of what donald trump said
before we get to what the doctor has now
said
people who is more competent who's got
whose mind
is sounder biden beats you in that well
i'll tell you what
uh let's take a test let's take a test
right now
let's go down joe and i will take a test
let him take the same test
that i took incidentally i took the test
too when i heard that you passed it yeah
how did you do
well it's not the hardest task no but it
has a picture and it says
and it's an element no no you see that's
all misrepresentation but that's what it
was on the web it's all
misrepresentation
because yes the first few questions are
easy but i'll bet you couldn't even
answer the last five questions i'll bet
you couldn't they get very hard the last
five
well one of them was count back from 100
by seven and let me tell you
if you couldn't answer you couldn't
answer
all right what's the question many of
the questions i get you the test i'd
like to give it but i guarantee you that
joe biden could not answer those
questions
okay and i answered all 35 questions
correctly
you so trump said the first few
questions are easy but i bet
you couldn't even answer the last five
questions they get very hard now it is
strange
in this is a test again meant to screen
out relatively serious
cognitive decline it's weird but by
saying chris wallace couldn't answer the
last five questions he's essentially
saying he believes chris wallace is
suffering from cognitive decline
now this entire portion of the interview
is crazy also because the test doesn't
have 35
questions although it's based on a
maximum score
of 30 points it doesn't have 35
questions and that's sort of a weird
thing for trump to say it is also crazy
for trump to say chris wallace couldn't
get the questions
right but now we have heard from dr ziad
nasradin
who developed this test and dr nasradeen
is now speaking out and saying
listen you know this this talk about
tough questions
doesn't make any sense this test is
supposed to be really
easy for anyone who's not cognitively
impaired trump talked about acing the
test
like it's some kind of an accomplishment
when he spoke to hannity i believe it
was last week
remember this one he didn't mean that
because he hasn't taken any cognitive
test because he couldn't pass one
i actually took one when i uh very
recently when i uh
when i was you know the radical left was
saying is he all there is he all there
and
i proved that was all there because i
aced it i aced the test
and he should take the same exact test a
very standard test i took
took it at walter reed medical center
in front of doctors and they were very
surprised they said that's an
unbelievable thing rarely does anybody
do what you just did
but he should take that same test but
now he has been totally taken
over aced the test i mean this is
ridiculous and dr ziad
nasradin said to market watch that quote
this is not an iq test or the level of
how a person is
extremely skilled or not the test is
supposed to help
physicians detect early signs of
alzheimer's
and it became very popular because it
was a short test
and very sensitive for early impairment
the normal score according to dr
nasradine
is 27 out of 30. the toughest part
is being given five words and then being
asked to recall them
after five minutes and then i believe
it's like after 10 minutes
and when you're in the middle of taking
a test this is the point
that part is sometimes the one that's
tougher for people
even not suffering from cognitive
impairment but beyond that
this is an easy test where the normal
score is almost perfect
the test cannot determine if somebody is
smart
the test cannot determine if somebody
has a high level of ability
and when trump said you know doctors
were shocked they had never seen someone
do what i did on this test it's
outrageous and it's laughable so the big
takeaways here are
trump said that the questions get tough
at the end that's not true
that's a concern number two trump said
he recently took it
we've not been told that trump took this
test since 2018
as far as we knew trump took the
montreal cognitive assessment in 2018.
so if trump was again tested recently it
would be
worth knowing why where and what the
circumstances were because that's not
actually been revealed
and number two again trump talks about
35 questions and the last few are hard
if he's talking about this test that's a
real problem if he was given
some other test then that would also be
important for the public to know and
then lastly
maybe most importantly trump doesn't
understand the nature of this test like
when he talks about acing it and
impressing doctors
this is a test where unless you're
suffering from cognitive decline
you do really well on it it's not that
doctors would go wow
wow you really did it you know it turns
out that that
that you're not actually suffering from
cognitive decline we're so impressed
with you mr president
that's weird and that's another question
now the other thing is
people don't even typically take this
test
unless there's a question about their
cognitive ability
now maybe because of all of the things
swirling around trump
trump looked for a test to take but it
also shouldn't be ignored that in normal
circumstances
this is a test that a physician would
suggest
if they have some reason to think it's
important
to screen out cognitive decline who
knows
every aspect of this just stinks to high
heaven
and as usual trump's discussions of the
test only raise
more questions how many questions are on
it why did trump find them tough
which test did he take who administered
it when did he take it why hasn't it
been mentioned or is he talking about
2018
i don't know that we're going to get
answers to these questions but the
important thing is
we don't really need any answers to
these questions to know he has to be
voted out
in just over three months that part is
clear and that's what's making this
increasingly simple
for more and more voters at least the
ones that i'm hearing from every day
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman also remember to get
the daily audio podcast on your favorite
podcasting app whether it's stitcher
itunes google play pandora
spotify we're on all of them get that
daily podcast
every single day usually around 3
eastern is when it's out
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video